okay so last year a massive tekken
tournament took place in saudi arabia
tekken gods from all over the world
converged on this one spot
to compete for their share of an over
100 000
prize pool in a glossy well-produced
tournament that meant great things
not just for the middle eastern tekken
scene but for tekken around the world
the problem it's been 16 months and
since then
none of the competitors have seen a
single cent
of their prize money
okay before i get into the specifics of
this particular story i gotta let you
guys know to head on over to twitch.tv
score esports because we're going live
pretty regularly these days
and there's great content on our twitch
channel that you can't find
anywhere on youtube so well over a year
ago in march of 2019
a series of esports events were held in
kobar saudi arabia
including the true gaming tekken
invitational
this single tekken tournament featured a
prize pool of one hundred
and ten thousand dollars usd which was
then the single
largest prize pool in tekken history for
a little context the 2018 tekken world
tour finals
had a prize pool of 25k and evo's tekken
prize pools
are even lower than that and heavy
hitters from around the world came to
participate in this thing
i'm talking the likes of kudans knee
chanel
nobi naroma arslan ash you get the
picture from a production standpoint the
true gaming tekken invitational looked
great they had an
awesome stage set up the stream quality
was good they had a commentator and
analyst desk great camera work
it was clean and in terms of the actual
game play competitively the tournament
was great
i mean we saw some of the best tekken
players of all time from all around the
world
give us some unforgettable hype moments
[Applause]
[Music]
but after all that confetti was cleaned
up after the stage was dismantled and
after the community's attention shifted
to other events
there remained one big problem
apparently
nobody got paid now this all hit the
public's attention in a big way only
recently
when tekken master a prominent fighting
game player and
one of the invitees to the true gaming
tekken invitational
tweeted about not receiving his prize
money from a different event that was
organized by the same people
now as far as the true gaming tech and
invitational goes the one with the
hundred thousand dollar prize pool
i talked to tech and master about it and
he said that
communication between the players who
are owed money and the company who
produced the event true gaming
hasn't exactly been productive when it
comes to when
how or even if they'll get their prize
money
after one month they they give you a
number to contact with
and every time they tell you like it's
where we are like on the process of
giving you the prices guys
um we'll be coming back to you and they
never come back
they tried to and every time like the
guy is saying
he still did not receive any like
funding
for the price he's promised you to
receive it like the next month
the one after every time it's delayed
rate rate until
um one year happened and still even
one year and a half actually nothing
happened
here's the thing though true gaming say
that they were hired
just to produce the event and that the
prize money
has nothing to do with them at all i
managed to get in contact with a guy
named ahmed al mustafa
who is the head of business development
at true gaming
and he says that the true gaming tekken
invitational
took place within a larger event called
gamerscon
he told me that the owner operator of
that event a company called chaol
events and exhibitions management co is
responsible for the prize money we
corresponded over email about it and let
me read to you
what he told me quote true gaming's role
in the event was to operate the
competitions and
gaming centered activities that have
relied on our gaming industry knowledge
and know-how
our team has been contacted by the
winners and has forwarded their
grievances to k-all
and have shared all contact information
directly to kal
so that there is a direct line of
communication and no delay
caused by layered communications in a
later email he also told me quote
we've tried to finalize this matter on
numerous occasions
we were even under the impression that
it was going to conclude at a sooner
time
and we are completely taken aback by how
chaol have let this drag
on for so long end quote it's worth
noting here that shortly after i got in
contact with true gaming
they released a public statement about
the matter that was very much in line
with what they told me privately
as far as this chaol events and
exhibitions management company goes
that's where the trail goes a little
cold for me
i tried calling them with a number on
their website and for me it didn't work
i tried tweeting at them i've emailed
them and i tried to use a contact form
on their website that is broken
apparently
so far as of the filming of this video i
haven't heard anything back from them
your call cannot be completed as dialed
please make sure you enter the correct
number
it's probably also worth noting here
that there were a bunch of other
invitational tournaments that took place
on the same weekend within this gamers
con that were all
organized by true gaming there was a
rocket league invitational there was a
fifa invitational and there was a smash
bros invitational
and like i said they were all organized
by true gaming who seem to be a company
who do everything from
esports centric youtube videos to
mainstream game reviews to
event production now let's just back up
for a quick second because there are
other entities involved in this issue
beyond just
the players true gaming and this k-all
events and exhibitions management
company
and i'm talking about agencies for the
saudi arabian government
see according to tech and master about
six months after the event when it
became
clear that they weren't going to get
their prize money any time soon
a lot of the participants in the true
gaming tech and invitational
got together and organized to try to
figure out what their next steps were
they went to a guy who goes by the tag
bert kane and he contacted
two saudi arabian government agencies
namely the general entertainment
authority in saudi arabia
and more pointedly the saudi arabian
federation for electronic and
intellectual sports
see the true gaming invitational had to
be sanctioned
by these bodies in order to put on their
event in the first place
and as to who this bert kane guy is he
is a saudi arabian esports scene
community leader and individual player
manager
who has served as a sort of go-between
between the players the
tos and the government agencies that
oversee esports in saudi arabia and he
told me that he's been in contact with
those government agencies and they are
actively investigating this situation as
we speak yes i have contacted the
federation on behalf of some
of the players and they did investigate
the issue
and i believe they have officially
contacted all the parties involved in
this case
and soon they will reach a resolve and
at least from where i'm sitting it's not
going to be easy to figure out who's
actually
on the hook for this money according to
tech and master bert kane and some other
folks i spoke to
nobody actually signed any kind of
contract or documentation that
stipulated how when or
i guess technically even if they would
get paid out
this prize money according to bert kane
esports and saudi arabia is still very
much
in a phase where contracts are not the
standard
what he supports itself in saudi is
still new
and it started based on community
efforts where almost everything was
based on
trust that moved along when esports
started to grow and many companies
started to throw big and huge events
everyone trusts what's being advertised
after all the law and saudi will hold
you accountable for what you advertise
let's say trust is what being practiced
here in saudi
i do believe that should change and
perhaps
what happens last year will uh
raise the awareness in the community
tekken master told me that players
basically got an email with some
graphics in it that told them when
where and how much and that was kind of
the extent of the documentation no
actually we just like an email from the
true gaming guy
that the price distribution is 100
k upon the top 8 and
the date of the tournament and that's it
we did not sign anything
so where does that leave players like
tekkenmaster or kudans who supposedly
won 60 000 from the true gaming tech and
invitational because there weren't any
contracts or documentation between the
players
and the organizers at least that i've
seen it's pretty hard from where i'm
sitting to figure out who
actually owes this money who is on the
hook for over a hundred thousand dollars
more than a year later true gaming say
that they actually have some
documentation that supposedly proves
that it's
all on chaol events and exhibitions
management company
and that true gaming had no financial
obligations whatsoever
in the tekken invitational but bert kane
tech and master and others say
they just aren't interested in what they
call excuses for non-payment
16 months after the fact from a player
perspective we really don't know about
what kind of agreements they have with
other companies or sponsors
and the players shouldn't get involved
in that as well
everything about the event say is true
gaming
and say is it's true gaming
responsibility the name
the tickets the invitations the
marketing campaign
i did see the statement published by
true gaming i think it's
too late for the statement more than a
year have
passed and a lot of people did ask about
the prizes
they also disabled comments on the
statements both
on twitter and in their website which
makes them
in a questionable position and it's not
what we waited
more than a year for this situation just
sucks
the true gaming invitational had by far
and away the largest prize pool in
tekken history
up until that point and instead of
standing as an example
of what that game's esports scene could
achieve
it's become an embarrassment but if
there's one positive outcome from this
fiasco
it's that it might just change saudi
arabian esports for the better
bert kane told me that this kind of
situation arises all too often in saudi
arabia
and that he is now working directly with
the saudi arabian federation
for electronic and intellectual sports
to develop a system
by which tournament organizers have to
prove
that they have the prize money that
they're promising before they're
sanctioned
to put on these events yeah back when
cyphus
started the investigation they started
to put preventative regulations
in place and this will be the score
exclusive
safes will soon launch a platform to
approve competitions
tournaments and everything related to
let's say esports competitions
basically if an event organizer wants to
host a tournament
he will need an approval to us that
specific tournament and to get an
approval
the event or tournament organizer will
have to submit his request
and deposit the prize pool at the same
time
when the tournament ends safes which is
the the federation the saudi federation
will transfer the prizes to the winners
and of course the
the organizer will have to report the
winners using the same
platform it sounds like a much needed
step towards stability
in a growing but vulnerable saudi
arabian esports scene
now as far as the true gaming tekken
invitational goes
we at this point have to put our faith
in the saudi arabian federation
for electronic and intellectual sports
and hope that
they not only determine who is actually
on the hook for this prize money
but crucially make sure that the players
who participated
are paid out what they were owed more
than a year and a half ago
alright so on a lighter tekken note did
you guys see
john ding's progress picks like oh my
god
this guy looks like a tekken character
he looks like some kind of character in
a fighting anime
got news for you though i reached out
and i got him to give me
his workout routine so you guys better
watch out man next don't at me next
clouded next top 10 you might be seeing
me you know
looking a little looking a little bit
like your boy kazuya
watch out got the devil chain speed and
weight
that was cringe i know